moi je retiens pas que c'est une
mauvaise année
[Musique]
je crois pour tout le monde à cause d'un
monter les prix mais ce n'est pas la
faute du gouvernement c'est mondial là
où je l'ai pris si on parle de
l'inflation la guerre enfin enfin le
virus et tout euh pas terrible alors on
nous assomme de la guerre du crâne de
coupure d'électricité de l'inflation la
réglementation des prix
augmentation des prix dans les
supermarchés la rencontre avec
les Égyptiens et d'Israël ça va bugging
je pense que c'est utile mais la guerre
en Ukraine la guerre encore est toujours
même les guerres qu'on en parle plus par
exemple l'Arabie Saoudite qui tape sur
le Yemen sélection de la coupe de
l'équipe de France de football pour la
Coupe du monde
fermé quoi c'est hyper étrange parce que
enfin il y a quand même eu beaucoup
d'évolutions par rapport au même à l'IVG
aux États-Unis et beaucoup d'évolution
dans les dernières années le même un peu
d'esclavage moderne par exemple il y a
eu aussi cette polémique de Shane où
tout le monde a envoyé des messages help
enfin moi je voyais beaucoup ça sur
TikTok et il y a eu un rôle à la
polémique des personnes qui
travaillaient dans le mauvais condition
tout ça j'aurais dû les élections
présidentielles
je suis retraité j'étais très heureux
c'est le fait d'être à la retraite et
d'être en bonne santé ça c'est la totale
vis-à-vis de la de l'être humain puisque
plutôt que de se faire la guerre on
devrait en ce moment mettre toutes nos
forces à réussir à sauver la Terre et le
climat alors que là qu'est-ce qu'on fait
on en rajoute on fait la guerre on ouvre
les mines de charbon le Garn extrait le
gaz liquéfié etc alors que c'est en
marche à côté de nos pompes
[Musique]
[Rires]
qui va faire beaucoup de dinguerie je
pense directement de ski Simone Veil
aussi parce que je suis allé voir le
film
[Musique]